when he's going to this gnarly building
it's like beyond sci-fi it's like the
tallest building on earth with this like
crazy they should have just had the
domain in each space yeah go all out
they have been going to space and ever
reaches the top floor die is because of
no oxygen floors up i partly had before
any of the craziness started to kick off
the actual plot I was just like oh we
refined to be up everybody who goes that
high will get a headache the building
like if you get a certain point does the
building like this way whoa falling over
like who what's the center of gravity
like what's going on reject nation Greg
Alva here John here we watch skyscraper
starring dwayne johnson who doesn't want
to be called the rock anymore but no
one's going to stop that from happening
and it also stars nevi campbell and it
stars the asian guy in the dark night
before going into this we got to give a
huge thank you huge to Donald Trump
the people at 40 X the actual 40 X
people for the X us all them on social
media this is no joke this is there's no
jokes in this video this is funny at all
okay I want try to be very sincere here
for a second before we watch this we
were like I'm sure 40 X will be cool
we've been on a couple of 40 X
experiences before what John and I both
weren't expecting and I really don't
want this to seem like we're over
selling it cuz that's all my I just want
to be very sincere it was surprisingly
the best 40 X experience I've ever been
a part of yeah I mean did you feel that
way I felt that way yeah yeah definitely
I mean it was the most fluid and the
most sort of fine-tuned of all of the
ones I've done so far some of the timing
for DX I can sometimes be like
distracted by the experience what the
effects are that's going on or I'm like
okay I get what for DX is trying to do
most the time it's really cool then
everyone
I have that moment this was a film that
I was like wow 4dx really made that
movie better yeah I can't look back on
that movie without thinking about my 40x
experience yeah it really did make it
immersive and especially certain effects
like especially the smoke effects
combined with the fans and stuff like
that it really yeah I was staring
through smoke at the rock there's a lot
of moving shots normally if we're gonna
think of theater for hooking it up we
keep it really brief what I really felt
like the 40x was such a big part of the
experience
yeah certain sequences of the V there's
a lot of attention there's a lot of fire
and there's a moment with ashes I heard
in the crowd people going oh and I was
like yeah each time we do a 40 X they
get a little more fine-tuned and that
was the finest tuned thus far so if I
were to recommend this film I highly
recommend watching this at a real 40x
theater especially if you can get the
ones with the heat vents we were at the
actual 40 X lab so they said there were
a couple of effects that might not be in
some theaters so I don't know like which
parts we should Susan Imogen I would
still say though that the majority of it
of what they say her and all the
theaters really did enhance like even
the motion shots and everything a lot of
the moving angles as for the movie
itself I'm trying to like separate
myself from the 40 excavatum battle yeah
I feel like this is a true 50 percent
movie it's got a solid 50 on Rotten
Tomatoes right now and I feel like
whether or not you like this is all
gonna depend on you and what you want
out of a summer blockbuster what you
want out of a doing Johnson movie
because I will say that a part of our
experience was definitely aided by the
40 X so in terms of the actual film
itself I'd say I enjoyed the film I
thought it would be stupider I wouldn't
say I was ever bored whenever there was
a stupid moment I'm like it's a
feel-good a bit dumber I'm gonna spoil a
tiny thing for you out of this crazy
film where the rock holds a bridge
together by himself
I'll brace the bridge you run
what do you said that everyone in the
theater laughed but I'm like most of
this movies not that dumb honestly the
big sequences they tease in the film
specifically the crane sequence where he
has to you know jump into the building
there was some really intense moments
some really intense shots where you
could feel the fear and suspense of the
heights we also see at the Rockwood
having you know a humor in his roles and
he does bring charisma and charm
performance but not since snitch have I
seen a film where he brings a lot of
drama to the role there's a little bit
more weight and he's not just a badass
this time he's like an actual fail I
mean it's always the rock trying to get
back to his family in some capacity but
always the rock with a former combat
experience yeah now I was a completely
different profession who's trying to
help his family and that's the formula
for a rock movie or for Dwayne Johnson
movie and he does bring a certain
element of a believable family man
quality to this while also being huge
physically enough to help suspend the
disbelief when he's doing things that
are clearly impossible by physics and
the opening of this movie I'm not gonna
give it away but you do see essentially
why he does have a peg leg
the proper term offensive like insulting
someone might like a prosthetic leg or
something like that just to be why he's
a walking pirate yeah most of this movie
is actually him on the sea I don't know
you see what happens and you see his
former profession when he's all buffed
out guy with this new job he's oh he
also got it he has a bit of an underdog
tail he's had to do this recovery when
he's going to this gnarly building by
the time the rock gets to like the plot
of him having to do a good job on this
deal he's working on he's in an underdog
position and I think him having that the
handicap of the prosthetic does come
into effect where you do have to root
for him to win and overcome obstacles a
lot of times these Dwayne Johnson films
you're like yeah he's got this handled
well I'm watching it going of course
he's gonna handle it I did have a little
a bit of the feeling of I am rooting for
him to actually overcome this yeah and
there is a mildly more engaging sense
for how is he gonna do this I guess yeah
I kind of want to see what he comes up
with I think the movie is really
entertaining it's it's fun it is a more
ridiculous version of a die-hard like
film for sure yeah you know gotta get to
the top of that freaking building bad
guys want something from guy who owns
this place he has a die-hard inside the
towering inferno yeah it really is also
I think a delightful surprise was Neve
Campbell nephew Campbell might be my
favorite thing about that movie pound
for pound I don't know if she's my
favorite thing I would say she's the
most surprising element of the movie
only because she's actually utilized and
is effective yeah she might be my
favorite part in terms of like
surprising qualitative presence yeah is
one of those things where I was like oh
wow
nah I because not only are you here at
all but also this is a pretty good
character and they they gave you
something to do when they cut back to
you I care you're not just the object
that the rock needs to get back I'm
point five times out of 10 you've
watched a review of people will go and
if Campbell's just so wasted in this
film she's not I really enjoyed her
performance I really enjoyed her
storyline I think her and Dwayne Johnson
I believe them as husband and wife I
think if you don't go on 40x like a
probably a forgettable experience summer
action movie it's just as under written
in a lot of places as you might be
expecting and for some viewers I can
totally imagine it not engaging you or
pushing you past the point of
ridiculousness but I still feel like
there are a good amount of people who
will have fun with it and I think if you
looked forward to this film it's gonna
give you exactly what you wanted or
which I say expected I think if you kind
of set the bar really low you might walk
away a little bit more surprised by how
some stuff actually does a really like a
good job and it makes it easier to
forgive dumb stuff in the film it's
appropriately harrowing the right stuff
like whenever he's like climbing a crane
or crawling around on the outside of the
building that stuff is like legitimately
I'm not especially afraid of heights I
feel like I'm afraid of heights within
reason those sequences and especially in
the 4dx they make your stomach
Rob yeah and I did like a lot of the
supporting cast too even though most of
them don't have character in the writing
really at all I thought they got a lot
of good actors to populate the movie
overall it's it's an enjoyable flick
with some ridiculousness but it strikes
a good enough tone to do like when dumb
stuff happens this game now whatever
yeah yeah something else on the way in a
couple minutes that'll probably and
there's and there's enough redeeming
moments and things to root for that I'm
like I would recommend this if like if I
were to steal a grading system I feel
for every review I gotta borrow up
someone else's rating system a different
one and I would probably borrow from the
flick pick and Chris tuck wins type of
rating system and I would probably give
this like a bee or a B+ hey you know I
give her like like a matinee I didn't
have so much fun with this that I'm like
I really like this but I did like it you
know I had a good time if you're the
kind of viewer who's jonesing for a
summer blockbuster I think you'll have a
good time no alcohol required alright
guys well what is your favorite Dwayne
Johnson movie and do you want to see the
Dwayne Johnson Rock and and who said
that better and Tom Cruise pair up for a
film because that's my dream action
movie ant-man in the rock that's mine do
it subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification Belka subscribe
buttons are broken and check us out on
patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly q and A's music video coverage
would love to have you become a patron
eject today